[Musique]
quelques chutes de
tir est en verre fils accroché à la
roche
[Musique]
des projets indigo il consiste à
développer des engins de pêche de la
petite particularité c'est qu'il faut
qu'elles sont au bio dégradable en
milieu marin
[Musique]
défilé traditionnel qui sont fabriqués à
partir de nylon par exemple ils vont
polluer l'environnement marin pendant
des centaines d'années l'avantagé du
fils a développé dans le cadre du projet
a un petit goût c'est que il va pouvoir
être utilisés pendant deux ans mais s'il
est perdu en deux ou trois ans on aura
vraiment un filet qui sait biodégrader
donc on va travailler avec des
plastiques qu'ils soient petro source et
donc d'origine pétrochimique ou alors
d'origine renouvelable ce qui nous
intéresse c'est vraiment le caractère
bio dégradable ont fait des tests en
laboratoire mais aussi en mer on met des
morceaux de file en mer et on va
regarder comment ça se dégrade dans le
temps et pour vérifier la biodégradation
là c'est en laboratoire on vient simuler
les conditions marine donc avec du sable
de l'eau de mer des bactéries des
microalgues des champignons et on vient
donner à manger notre plastique à ces
micro organismes
on va regarder si les micro-organismes
marins ils vont être susceptibles de
venir grignoter ce plastique qui sera au
fond de l'eau
[Musique]
donc l'idée c'est d'impliquer en fait
les pêcheurs dans le cycle dans le
processus de conception jours à prévoir
quand ils utilisent le prototype du
filet est ce qu'il ya des modifications
comment est-ce qu'ils vont l'utiliser
comment ils se l'approprient c'est ça
vraiment le gros objectif pour
identifier les contraintes en fait qu'il
ya dans l'activité de pêche il ya une
attente en tout cas une demande et après
6,6 à pêche bien tant mieux l activité
de pêche c'est quand même une activité
commerciale typiquement ce qui ressort
généralement c'est la question du prix
et pourtant c'est quelque chose qui est
important mais ça va pas forcément
freiner donc l'adoption
[Musique]
derrière ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça peut évidemment participer à la
protection de l'environnement ce qui est
important pour eux évidemment parce que
il travaille avec les ressources marines
dont la protection de l'environnement
c'est plus ou moins la pérennisation
aussi de leur métier il ya 80% de la
pollution marine qui est issu de ses
activités terrestres et seulement 20%
qui sont issus des activités maritimes
dont le milieu de la pêche qui
représente une très infime quantité
finalement mais c'est vrai que il faut
essayer de proposer des alternatives
parce que les pêcheurs sont souvent
pointées du doigt vente est très
volontiers s'il ya beaucoup de plastique
en mer il ya peu qu'une file à tous les
bouteilles en plastique ça qu'on ramasse
tous les jours tous les jours rahmani de
caisse des emballages des bouteilles et
boîtes de conserve
on note toujours ramassé en fait ça fait
des années qu'on fasse on ce qu'on
trouve dans le filet on le ramène à
terre ça se voit pas forcément mais tous
les jours nous c'est notre environnement
on veut préserver quand même notre outil
de travail
[Musique]